there's something
[Music]
this is the feeling I've been searching
for my entire life
[Music]
stop the hate is celebrate what the Lord
has given us
with me my job ain't to follow the law
my job is to interpret it
Hey
I've tried to be a better human being
[Music]
[Applause]
you are dealing with something that has
never occurred on this planet
there are things
and you're better off not understanding
[Applause]
and I want to know what happened that
night
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not sure about this part I want to
be President for all Americans I mean do
I you know all of them
[Applause]
hey everybody its Charlie as we all
expected HBO dropped some new Game of
Thrones footage so we have to break down
now they dropped it as part of this
really big trailer but the scene that
they showed is from season 8 episode 1
it's basically the opening scene so
there's a new round of that book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video there's a whole bunch of other
footage in here too obviously we'll talk
about all the Game of Thrones stuff
first but I know a lot of you are asking
questions about Watchmen and obviously
there's His Dark Materials the Golden
Compass that HBO will be airing episodes
for so I'll talk about that stuff at the
end of the video just a reminder about
the release date is April 14th we're
almost within the 1 month window so what
we're seeing at the start here is all
the Ravens flying west along the wall
implying the torment and beric
Dondarrion were able to get a raven off
to Castle black edie
and the other brothers of the Nights
Watch that stayed at Castle black during
season 7 remember there's barely any
brothers of the Nights Watch the whole
reason why the wildlings went to man
eastwatch-by-the-sea was because none of
the other Lords of the north wanted to
spare any of their people Cersei
obviously wasn't gonna send them any
reinforcements so torment sort of called
them all out on it in that council
meeting and said well I guess it's
basically up to us now so that was the
TV show's version of giving the
wildlings that land on the gift because
during the books they make it south of
the wall and they had to figure out what
to do with them next so in the books
they granted them that portion of land
but on the TV show they just went an all
manned eastwatch-by-the-sea r.i.p most
of them probably died during that but
just because the Ravens are flying to
Castle black doesn't necessarily mean
that that's also where barrack and
torment went because all they would need
to do is let IDI know what happened and
tell him to get his ass to Winterfell
with any surviving brothers of the
Nights Watch there's no reason to man
the wall anymore
the White Walkers are coming south so
everybody make a beeline for Winterfell
so I'm guessing that they probably pull
a Gendry and do the world's fastest dash
to Winterfell and just show up in the
first episode like you guys have no idea
what's going on until bran wheels and it
goes no actually I can work Ravens I saw
everything that happened so no worries I
got them up to speed that's the
advantage of having someone like bran is
that you don't actually need to send
Ravens to Winterfell because he controls
the Ravens and sends them out to get
information then there
a shot of drogon flying over Denise's
army as they marched right through
winter town if you don't know where
winter town is that's the little town
that's right south of Winterfell so
pretty much anybody that comes to
Winterfell from the south passes through
there on their way up
that's where Tyrion was in the pilot
episode when Jaime went to find him when
they were having that big scene of
Robert Baratheon and the Lannisters
marching in to meet all of the Starks
he's like I'll go find my brother he's
probably in the brothel so this is
happening in winter town you can
actually see the little huts in the
wooden buildings behind them here you
don't really get a sense for the scale
of drogon in this shot here but the
visual effects artists say that one of
the scales on his hide is bigger than
season one drogon so the Dragons have
continued to grow since the end of
season seven not that much time has
passed but you have to imagine that it
would take them a couple weeks to March
everyone to Winterfell so even though
they do use a lot of fast travel seemed
to scene where they'll just jump all the
way over Westeros like how did he get
here so fast when you take everything
into context it still took them a long
time to get this far but I love the way
they open the shot with the unsullied
legions I'm guessing this is also the
way that they reveal that opening scene
- with them marching in then you get the
slow reveal of everyone else then you
finally see Jon and Daenerys you can't
really pick out grey worm underneath any
of these helmets here but you can see
the Dothraki bloodrider 'he's marching
on the horses behind them you probably
recognized cono from season 7 he's sort
of her chief blood rider but as the
camera follows drogon as they march
north to Winterfell through winter town
you get the first real shot of Arya that
we've seen seen drogon freaking out and
then you see her expression changed to
wonder like oh my god this is the
greatest thing that I've ever seen in my
entire life and I just killed all the
phrase in a reverse red wedding by
stealin Walder Frey's face right now
because all these peasants are behind
her - I'll talk about them in a second
because their reactions are really funny
when you look at Arya like look in the
background as they're freaking out
they have voiceover and a music track on
this so you don't actually hear their
screams like oh my god it's a dragon
this also looks like it's happening in
that same scene so she happens to be in
winter town watching the army marched
through before they make it to
Winterfell and you get that big
introduction scene obviously they don't
show you Jon Snow and Daenerys you have
to imagine what this opening scene is
probably going to be like - and I like
the way that they're using Arya's
perspective
show this like she's the one whose eyes
are tracking drogon as he flies over the
army but this is sort of a nicer version
of Daenerys bringing her armies to
King's Landing in the season 7 finale
and them having that big meeting in the
dragon pit they'll be meeting in the
Great Hall of Winterfell to talk about
battle planning shortly after this but
Daenerys is basically making the
grandest possible entrance that she ever
could the greatest entrance that anyone
at Winterfell has ever seen in its many
thousands of years of history also
probably the greatest intro to any
season of Game of Thrones ever in season
7 was actually really cool with that
Arya reverse red wedding but it's
probably one of those slow reveals
situations like remember at the
beginning of season 7 also right after
that red wedding scene you get the slow
reveal of the army of the Dead marching
through winter the White Walkers the
night king slowly being unveiled so it's
sort of like Daenerys is army in this
version is slowly being unveiled you see
the shot of the unsullied legions then
you see as they pass by you see all the
blood riders then you see the Dragons
then they probably revealed Jon Snow and
Daenerys and it's sort of like Arya just
looking at them and wonder like this is
so amazing I'm so happy to be here then
she sees Jon but it's hard to tell just
from this footage whether or not they're
separating a lot of the reunions in Arya
has her reunion with jon snow in winter
town before they head to Winterfell and
go through the gates because obviously
Daenerys probably isn't gonna try and
shade Sansa and the Lords of the north
the way that she shaded Cersei when they
showed up at the end of season 7 for
their bit meeting in the dragon pit
she'll probably land the dragons outside
the outer walls maybe stopped the blood
riders and the unsullied legions a good
distance away and then just take a small
party of her closest inner-circle
through the main gates like you have
surged aura with her here Varys Tyrion
Miss and I gray wormer also probably in
the background of there somewhere too
but it actually would be really cool if
Jon had a little reunion with Arya
before that big opening scene of them
walking through and it would make sense
that you would try to separate that out
just to give it its own distinct moment
like Jon was the person that she was
closest to growing up so it makes sense
that that would be the most impactful
reunion right at the beginning like I
haven't seen you in so long look at all
the things that we've been through now
we have to go through and actually get
to the business of defending the realm
then they go through they have that big
meeting with Sansa so you guys let me
know in the
do you actually think that the Aria
reunion takes place here in winter town
before the big meeting with Sansa
Daenerys and John inside the walls at
Winterfell then you get the Sansa
reunion we already talked about that and
what her attitude towards Daenerys is at
the beginning of the season then you
have the scenes of them inside the Great
Hall with Daenerys as costume change
with that look on her face like she's
really happy to be here she wants to be
a team player she's really happy to meet
Jon Snow's family you just have to
imagine that sonses on the other side of
the table just staring daggers back at
her the actors have also been doing
official press recently sophie turner
revealed even though we don't see it any
of the footage here that Sansa actually
gets to wear a version of armor this
season not Stark armor like you see
Jaime wearing or Jon Snow the way she
describes it is just thicker versions of
stark leather with extra intricate
northern designs so imagine the way that
Cersei has changed her costume between
season 7 and season 8 she has those
armor looking shoulder pads her season 8
costume looks even more like it's
armored up even though technically she's
not wearing armor there's a shot of the
night king with his ice javelin I'm
assuming that some of these are actually
from the end of season 7 episode 6 when
he was going after them and they were
trying to escape on dro Khan's back the
one new bit of this though does look
like it's vissarion and the knight came
flying through the wreckage of the wall
as it comes tumbling down because it's
happening during daytime not during
nighttime when it happened during season
7 episode 7 so this might be either
extra footage leftover from the end of
season 7 or just an early shot of than
just recapping what's happening at the
beginning of the season because I did a
video about the official cast list for
episode 1 in the night king actor is not
listed in it so maybe it's just because
he's a background CG shot and they
didn't need him on set that day so we
wouldn't take it too seriously but look
a little more details like that as we
get closer to the season usually we
don't find out exact run times and
episode titles until it's right before
episodes air but most of the footage
we've seen so far as we know is actually
from season 8 episode 1 at the beginning
of the episode which isn't a big
surprise but I'm expecting that they'll
probably drop a proper trailer sometime
if it's not later today then it'll be in
the next two weeks or so but if we hear
anything about that I will totally do a
video about it post all your reactions
to the Game of Thrones footage in the
comments below
there's obviously extra footage in here
for the deadwood movie that's coming out
later this year with Seth
Bullock talking to Ian McShane zal
Swearengen probably dropping a lot of
f-bombs there's a new scene from
Watchmen with Jeremy Irons as older
Adrian veep blowing out a candle on his
birthday cake the cake is just coloured
to look like his watchman costume so
that's just them sort of winking at the
camera he kind of smiles at it like I
see what you did here you made me a
birthday cake like my old costume the
other big surprise is they also include
footage for His Dark Materials season 1
the Golden Compass so this is James
McAvoy as Lord Asriel little Daphne
Keane x-23 from the Logan movie playing
Lyra and Ruth Wilson as Marissa Coulter
there's no release date for it yet it's
a BBC production but they will be airing
episodes on HBO inside the United States
what'll happen is is I was actually
working on a totally different Game of
Thrones video when all this footage
drops so I'll post that in the next day
or two and I'll name a giveaway winner
when I do that so while you wait for
everything click here for all my other
Game of Thrones season 8 teaser and
trailer videos and click here for my new
season 8 House Stark promo and
predictions thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight